في فبراير الماضي مشاهدينا طبقت بريطانيا
وويلز قانون الحد الادنى لسن الزواج من 16
عاما الى 18 عاما كل هذا في اطار حمايه
الفتيات القصر من الزواج القصري والان ما
تدرسه مصر في ظل ارتفاع عدد حالات الطلاق
من جهه وايضا للحد من النمو السكاني طبعا
عده مؤسسات طرح التوصيات برفع سن الزواج
لاكثر من 18 عاما يصل الى واحد وعشرين
ايضا بدا جهه حكوميه رسميه تتعاطى مع
المقترح بجديه اكبر ووافقه احصائيات رسميه
في مصر فانوس بك كبيره من الفتيات
المطلقات قاصرات ونتج عن ذلك زياده حالات
الطلاق الى حاله كل دقيقتين خلال العام
الماضي بعدما كانت قبل 12 عاما حاله كل
سبع دقائق
[موسيقى]
هناك قانون لعدم زواج القاصرات لكن هذا
القانون ما الهدف منه اولا هو
يعني رغم ان انا مؤيد لرفع سن الزواج
بالنسبه للشباب
بالجنسين وهقول لحضرتك باختصار شديد لك
لان احنا عندنا النهارده نسبه كبيره جدا
من الطلاق بتم بسبب الزواج في سن مبكر
الزواج في سن مبكر
البنت والولد ما بيبقوش لسه قادرين على
تحمل الاعباء الاسريه مره واحده بتلاقي
نفسها مسؤوله عن بيت مسؤوله عن اسره قله
التجارب الحياتيه بالنسبه لها منقوله من
نمط حياتي معين الى نمط حياتي اخر وهكذا
الحاجات دي كلها بتخليها بتواجه عمليه
زواج حديثه بالنسبه لها فبتفشل الحياه
الزوجيه وبالتالي وبالتالي حالات الطلاق
بتزيد في حالات الطلاق بتؤثر
بزياده الاعباء القضايا في المحاكم من
نفقه وطلاق
وتمكين المنزل زوجيه وتبديد منقولات زوجيه
وخلافه
عايز اقول ان احنا النهارده عندنا تخيلي
لما نيجي نقول مثلا عندنا لا يقل عن 130
الف فتاه متزوجه من سن 10 لسن 17 سنه لا
هذا خمسه هذا القاصرات يعني في قانون
اعتقد في مصر
في مصر لا موجود موجود بس بيتم التحايل يا
سيدي الفاضل موجود القانون وتم رفع ورفع
سن الزواج لحد الادنى له 18 سنه لكن بيتم
التحايل على هذا بالزواج القاصرات على
اساس ان هو بيتعمل بزواج عرفي وعشان كده
ما فيش تجريم للزواج العرف فده سبب عشان
كده انا بانادي بان نرفع سن الزواج معين
لكن مش على اطلاقه لكن هيقابلنا مشكله في
رفع سن الزواج انا عندي مواد الدستور
بتمنع ذلك يعني عندي مواد الدستور في
القانون النهارده الدستور بيقول ان
المساواه بين الحقوق والحاجبات ولا يمكن
تقييم اي حريه بالنسبه للشخص او الولد او
البنت اي قانون يقيد حريته
[موسيقى]